the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi welcome once again to our lectures in
calculus revisited where today we are
going to talk about the calculus of
composite functions now recall that we
have already mentioned in previous
lectures the notion of a composite
function and what we're going to do
today is to emphasize the idea as to how
often we are called upon to find
functional relationships where the first
variable is given in terms of a second
variable and the second variable say is
given in terms of the third variable and
we wish to find say the first variable
in terms of a third fact here is where
the name the chain rule seems to come
from a chain reaction where the
variables are related in a chain this
way now we can see this quite easily in
terms of a diagram suppose for example
that I have a graph of X versus Y and
suppose also I have a graph of T versus
X without any reference to calculus this
is rather important without any
reference to calculus notice that these
two graphs together allow me to
visualize Y in terms of T for example
given a particular value of T let's call
it T sub one given a value of T from
that value of T I can find the
corresponding value of X let's call that
X sub one now knowing X sub one I can
come to this diagram knowing what X sub
one is I can find Y sub one and so you
see in this chain of two diagrams a
particular value of T allows me to find
a particular value of y and in this
particular way I can visualize Y as a
function of T and you see at this stage
of the game there is absolutely no need
to have to have any knowledge of
calculus to understand what it is that
we're discussing okay the place that
calculus comes in is in the following
way let's suppose it happened in this
first
diagram that the graph of y versus x was
smooth in other words let's assume that
Y is a differentiable function of X in
particular the way I've drawn this
diagram here we're saying suppose dy DX
evaluated at x equals x1 happens to
exist and suppose also that this graph
of X versus T this also happens to be a
smooth curve in other words that X is a
differentiable function of T again in
the language of calculus what we're
saying is the slope of this curve exists
at this particular point and it's given
by DX DT evaluated at T equals t1 now
without going into a proof at this stage
all we're saying is this
we suspect that if Y is a differentiable
function of X and X is a differentiable
function of T that therefore Y should
also be a differentiable function of T
notice it's not a conjecture at all that
if Y is a function of X and X is a
function of T that Y is a function of T
that part is clear the conjecture is
that we suspect that if Y is a
differentiable function of X and X is a
differentiable function of T that Y will
be a differentiable function of T in
still other words our suspicion is
perhaps that a differentiable function
of a differentiable function is again a
differentiable function but even more to
the point not only do we suspect for
example that dy DT exists here when t
equals t1 but in line with our lecture
of last time we might even begin to
suspect in terms of this fractional
notation that not only does the Y DT
exist at T equals t1 but it can be found
by multiplying dy DX evaluated at x
equals x1 by DX DT evaluated at T equals
t1 again almost as if the DX from the
numerator here cancelled with the DX
from the NAM
they hear the same as what we hope our
differential notation would be and the
question is granted that we would like a
result like this to hold true in a
course such as calculus where we're
working with very tiny numbers and
quotients of small numbers places where
we've seen that our intuition often
leads us astray it becomes fairly
apparent that we had better have
something stronger than just intuition
in helping us derive certain results no
matter how natural these results might
look now the way we proceed here is as
follows again and notice again the
building blocks of calculus we go back
to the fundamental result of last time
you see after all to find dy DT we want
Delta Y divided by delta T and then
we'll take the limit as delta T
approaches zero the question is first of
all do we have a nice expression for
Delta Y and in terms of the lecture of
last time we saw that if Y was a
differentiable function of X at x equals
x1 that Delta Y was given by dy DX
evaluated at x equals x1 times Delta X
plus K times Delta X and this is crucial
now where the limit of K as Delta X
approaches zero one zero now you see
this recipe here is ironclad I emphasize
it from a geometric point of view last
time but you may recall that I proved it
from an analytical point of view in
other words whether you want to
visualize this or derive it it makes no
difference the key fact is that this
statement here is ironclad it's
something that we now know to be true in
our so-called game of calculus the point
is again now how do we use this to check
over our conjectured result again the
answer is almost straightforward if you
keep track of these things you'll notice
that calculus is a one step at a time
procedure namely we want dy DT that
suggests we first want Delta Y divided
by delta T and then we'll take the limit
as delta T approaches zero so first we
do this namely starting with unknown
recipe we divide
through by delta T and why can we do
this we can do this because of course
delta T is not zero now we take the
limit of both sides of the Equality as
delta T approaches zero we observe that
on the left hand side the limit of Delta
Y divided by delta T as delta T
approaches zero is precisely dy DT and
in this particular case evaluated at T
equals t1 in other words notice that the
left hand side here as we let delta T
approaches zero becomes the left hand
side of our conjecture
now we recall again that the limit of
the sum is the sum of the limits and we
now take the limit of each of these
terms separately each term is a product
the limit of a product is the product of
the limits dy DX evaluated at x equals
x1 is a constant in fact that's just
what it's dy the limit of dy DX
evaluated at x equals x1 as delta T
approaches zero is just dy DX evaluated
at x equals x1 on the other hand by
definition the limit of Delta X divided
by delta T as delta T approaches zero is
just the X TT and keeping track of the
subscripts here later on will become
sloppy and leave these subscripts out
there really is no great harm done in
calculus of a single variable we shall
find in calculus of several variables
that is extremely important to keep
track of the subscripts and what
variables are where the variables are
being evaluated and things of this
particular type but I just want to get
you used to the fact that these are
specific numbers that we're using over
here now let's continue we take the
limit of this term as delta T approaches
zero we observe that this becomes DX DT
and the limit of K as delta T approaches
zero well as delta T approaches zero the
fact that X is a differentiable function
of T means that Delta X approaches zero
and since the limit of K as Delta X
approaches 0 is zero this term becomes
zero
zero times anything is any finite number
is zero that means that this term here
in the limit becomes zero and we're left
with the desired result but notice that
we did not arrive at this desired result
by hand-waving we did not say this term
Delta X is getting small so it's
becoming negligible I can't emphasize
this point enough that it is true that
Delta X is becoming small here but so is
delta T and that indicates essentially
your 0 over 0 form and the thing that
saves us the thing that makes this whole
term drop out is the key fact that K
itself goes to 0 as Delta X goes to 0 by
the way there are easier ways of
intuitively trying to remember the chain
rule for example one way that people
often try to visualize the chain rule is
this they say okay we want dy DT so
let's take Delta Y divided by delta T
and then we'll take the limit as delta T
approaches 0 now you see in this
notation here Delta Y and Delta T are
actually numbers as numbers we can write
these things in fractional notation and
we could write what that Delta Y divided
by delta T is Delta Y divided by Delta x
times Delta X divided by delta T then we
could take the limit as delta T
approaches 0 and we would arrive at the
same result but again without trying to
make this thing too obnoxiously long
here the thing to keep in mind is that X
is a function of T and from a rigorous
point of view the danger with the
shortcut technique and it can be patched
up but requires a great deal of
mathematical analysis the danger here is
that as delta T approaches 0 it's quite
possible that Delta X will be 0 in other
words it's possible that for a given
change in T there is no change in X now
if Delta X happens to equal 0 then we're
in trouble over here in other words in
many cases the shortened version gives
us an idea as to what's going on but our
so-called
longer method has no pitfalls to it but
enough said for what the for this recipe
is this result is known as the chain
rule this result is known as the chain
rule and this will be the topic of the
rest of today's lecture now let's take a
look at some of these things in a bit
more detail for example let's look at an
illustration suppose we want to find
dy/dx if y is equal to x squared plus 1
squared let me first do this problem in
the wrong way let's put a question mark
over here and you know people learn
things like what bring the exponent down
and replace it by one less now certainly
if I bring the exponent down here and
replace it by one less this is the
answer that I get
of course the question is is this the
right answer well you see notice one
very nice way about finding out whether
an answer is wrong is to first find out
by another way which is the right answer
for example if y equals x squared plus 1
squared it happens that we know how to
square this thing we can find directly
that another way of expressing Y is what
it's x to the fourth plus 2x squared
plus one but we have previously learned
how to differentiate a polynomial
drooler polynomial is what this is only
what for x cubed plus 4x and you see
somehow or other this does not seem to
give if this is the well for one thing
we see that these are two different
answers for another thing if this is the
one that happens to be the right answer
this is the one that is the wrong answer
and since we know from previous material
this is the right answer
there is something wrong with this
regardless of how right it might look in
fact how much are we off by over here if
we factored out a 2 that was if we
factor this thing out what can we do we
can write this as 4x times x squared
plus 1 and what we really had over here
was twice X square
plus one it seems that the correction
factor is 2x now again notice that the
derivative of what's inside the
parentheses over here just happens to be
exactly 2x now how does the chain rule
come into play in a problem of this type
you see the thing is that what we should
do over here is rewrite this namely for
example let u equal x squared plus 1
then what this says is what Y is equal
to u squared where u is equal to x
squared plus 1 see this is just another
way of writing this and in this
particular form the chain rule seems to
be emphasized more you see Y is a
function of U U is a function of X
notice that from the first equation it
is relatively easy to find dy to you in
fact it's just what to you will write
that down later
the from the second equation it's easy
to find the U DX and by the chain rule
all we're saying is that the why do u
times du/dx is dy/dx C what will that
give us in this case dy the U is 2 u du
u DX is 2x that gives us 4x times u U is
x squared plus 1 and so this becomes 4x
times x squared plus 1 and if we now
compare this with what was the correct
answer we see that in this case
everything worked out fine I suppose
what we should do here is to comment now
on the danger of memorizing recipes
without thoroughly understanding them
the idea that said when you want to
differentiate something raised to a
power that you bring the power down and
replace it by one less hinged on the
fact that the thing that was being
raised to the power was the same
variable with respect to which you were
doing the differentiation you see for
example when we had y equals
squit and then we wrote that the ydx is
2x the thing that was important over
here was the fact that what the thing
that was being raised to the second
power is precisely the variable with
respect to which we were doing the
differentiation you see in the problem y
equals x squared plus 1 squared the
thing that was being raised to the
second power was x squared plus 1 the
variable with respect to which we were
differentiating was X in other words to
write this thing more symbolically if Y
is equal to something squared then the
derivative that's equal to twice that
something is the derivative of Y with
respect to that something you see the
place the chain rule comes in is when
the variable which appears here is not
the same as the variable which appears
here and we'll see this in greater
detail as we go along by the way the
chain rule comes up in another form
known as parametric equations and this
form comes up very often that's a twist
of what we were talking about before
this is the situation in which
frequently we want to compare two
variables let's call them x and y
alright and it happens that both
variables x and y can be expressed more
simply in terms of a third variable t
and frequently what one does is tries to
talk about the relationship that exists
between y and x in terms of eliminating
t between these two equations by the way
in terms of differential language there
seems to be an easy way of handling this
namely you see if we differentiate the
first equation we get what that dy DT is
F prime of T if we differentiate the
second equation we get that the ex DT is
G prime of T now if as we said in our
last lecture we can pretend that this is
really a fraction
that it's dy / DT in other words if we
think of dy as being delta y-tan
of DX as being Delta X 10 and DT as
being delta T it would appear that we
could say what that dy DT / DX DT would
just be what dy DX in other words dy /
DT / DX / DT which is what this would
say if this was in differential form
would just be dy DX in other words we
get the feeling that to find the
derivative here all we have to do is
differentiate Y with respect to T and
divide that by the derivative of X with
respect to T C and by the way you see
this becomes a particularly powerful
tool in those computational cases where
we do not know how to eliminate T and to
solve specifically for Y in terms of X
you see in terms of this particular
recipe over here we are allowed to leave
X and y in terms of T again the same old
Bugaboo comes up to plague us the fact
that something seems natural is not
enough to allow us to believe that is
actually correct is there a more
rigorous way of obtaining the same
result again the answer is yes and not
only is the answer yes but it goes back
to the fundamental recipe that we were
discussing in our previous lecture
namely we know that Delta Y is f prime
of T times delta T plus k1 delta T and
that Delta X is g1 prime of T G prime of
T times delta T plus K 2 delta T where
both the limit of k1 and k2 as delta T
approaches 0 and this is a notation I
think it takes a while to get used to
we're used to seeing what is like K
stands for constants but it's important
over here to understand that k1 and k2
are functions of delta T that the
difference between Delta Y and Delta
why 10 Delta X and Delta X 10 that
difference which is K Delta X or K Delta
Y depending on which problem we're
dealing with that certainly K in that
case does depend the difference between
is derivative K does depend on how big
Delta T happens to be at any rate the
important thing is that as delta T
approaches zero these go to zero also
now you see if we take this and actually
compute Delta Y divided by Delta X and
we write this a little bit more
suggestively factor out a delta T from
both numerator and denominator since
rigorously tells us what Delta Y divided
by Delta X is now we take the limit as
Delta X approaches zero that by
definition is what that's by definition
dy/dx where you see first of all as
Delta X approaches a delta T is not zero
we're assuming since it's not zero can
be canceled out and once we've canceled
out delta T notice that as delta T
approaches zero so those Delta X as
Delta X approaches 0 as delta T that
makes k1 and k2 go to zero and then
since the limit of a quotient is the
quotient of the limits provided only the
G prime of T is not zero we see that in
the limiting process we get the same
answer and by the way you see once we
get the same answer as we would have got
the short way then we can use the
convenience of the short recipe however
the fact that the short recipe was nice
is not enough of a guarantee that was
giving us the correct answer as a case
in point it's rather interesting to
point out that if you want the second
derivative in other words let's recall
what we have here we have what Y was
given to be say f of T X was given by G
of T and you see from these two
equations
what we could do is find what we could
find the second derivative of Y with
respect to T and we could also find from
this equation the second derivative of X
with respect to T this we could
certainly do and mechanically we could
certainly say let's cancel the common
denominator the interesting thing is
that when you form that quotient
whatever that quotient is it does not
come out to be the second derivative of
Y with respect to X and there is an
interesting piece of folklore over here
I don't know if this ever bothered you
or not but it used to bother me I never
understood why when you talk about the
second derivative that the exponent was
written between the D and the variable
in one case but written at the end in
the other case in other words notice
that the two here appears between the D
and the Y but in the denominator the D
appears outside and again it was the
foresight of the fathers of differential
calculus notice rather interestingly
that if mechanically you did agree to
cancel the common denominator here that
what you would wind up with is not d2y
DX squared but rather what d 2y d 2x in
other words if you mechanically carried
this out notice that the notation would
be incorrect the two comes out to be in
the wrong place over here you see again
the interesting point is we don't have
to rely on taking my word for it
somebody might say to me now look at all
you've told me is is I get the wrong
answer solving the solving this problem
this particular way and you given me a
nice lecture about how the tools come
out the wrong way and everything how do
I know that this is the wrong answer C
and E again everything comes back to
fundamentals again to find d2y DX
squared observe that by definition
that's just DDX of dy/dx see that
definition doesn't depend on what
functions we're dealing with the second
derivative with respect to X is the
derivative with respect
the X of the first derivative now once
we have this you see knowing from our
previous case that what dy/dx was F
prime of T divided by G prime of T we
can now do what take this derivative by
the way again notice how the chain rule
comes up in practice it's not always
dictated to us if you look at the
expression inside the parentheses what
do we have inside the parenthesis we
have a function of T only this is a
function of T we want to differentiate
it with respect to X the most natural
variable to differentiate a function of
T with respect to is T itself in other
words what would have been nice is if
this was the derivative of F prime of T
over G prime of T with respect to T see
this would be easier to handle we would
then use the quotient rule etc you see
we can differentiate a function of T
with respect to T the trouble is we have
the derivative respect to X and if we
just change this to a T that's cheating
see I mean you pretend you copy it wrong
because it's an easier problem to solve
that way the beauty of the chain rule is
that it allows us to do the problem the
easier way and to doctor up the
resulting incorrect answer by the right
answer namely you see what we wanted to
wind up with here was what the
derivative not with respect to T but
with respect to X and so by using the
chain rule you see we do what we take
the derivative with respect to T
multiply that by DT DX again
mechanically almost as if T's canceled
but this is the way the chain rule works
and now you see I can work this out by
the regular quotient rule which says
what it's the denominator times the
derivative of the numerator C and I'm
differentiating out respect to T the
natural variable minus the numerator
times the derivative of the denominator
over the square of the denominator now
that's a mess by itself meaning what
computationally it's not that obvious I
mean it's quite a bit of work to do here
and then that whole thing must be
multiplied by DT DX and this you see is
how one goes around finding the second
derivative of Y with respect to X in
terms of parametric equations and more
than once if you're not careful you're
going to find yourself making serious
mistakes by forgetting to put in this
factor of DT DX by the way an
interesting point is that we have not
computed DT DX we have computed DX DT
remember X was e so let's go back here
see X was G of T so from that DX DT is G
prime of T and the question is if DX DT
is G prime of T how does one find DT DX
and again I think your intuition is
going to tell you to just take
reciprocals and again the question is
it's true that this suggests taking
reciprocals but how do we know that we
can do this and if we can do this what
does it really mean you see what this is
leading into is what's going to be the
subject of our lecture next time called
inverse functions and just to give you a
preview of what that lecture is about
and how we work things like this let's
take a look at what we mean by inverse
functions well we won't even mention it
in much detail but let's take a look and
see what's going on over here let's
suppose that the first and by the way
I've started to abandon using the T over
here all the time I think those of us in
engineering work primarily keep thinking
of T as being time and you may get the
mistaken notion that if the variable
isn't time the thing doesn't work this
way in most cases physically the
variable that we're interested in will
be time but just for the idea of getting
you used to the fact that it makes no
difference what the name of the variable
is I've taken the liberty of running
slightly differently namely I now assume
that Y is a differentiable function of U
and that U is a differentiable function
of X by the chain rule I now know that
the that Y is a differentiable function
of X and that the Y DX is dy du u times
du u DX
the interesting thing here is is that
there is nothing in the statement of the
chain rule that says that the first
variable and the third that x and y must
be different variables in fact it might
happen that x and y are synonyms for one
other if x and y happen to be synonyms
suppose x and y are synonyms look what
happens over here dy/dx is then just dy
dy which is 1c let's write that down
let's see Y dy this would be dy D U and
if X is equal to Y this is the u dy and
if this is equal to 1 and this is dy D U
and this is the u dy what does this tell
us about the relationship between D Y D
U and the u dy it says their product is
1 and if the product is 1 that by
definition means that the two factors
are reciprocals now what I wanted to
observe over here is what this whole
thing means namely if Y happens to equal
X do you see what this thing says it
says that Y is a differentiable function
of U and U in turn is a differentiable
function of Y that's precisely what we
meant when we talked about inverse
functions we don't know what an inverse
function exists all we're saying is is
that if F inverse happens to exist over
here to find D u dy all we have to do is
take the reciprocal of dy du u now again
this is going to be the subject of our
next lecture all I wanted to do was to
make this aside for the time being what
I want to do to complete today's lecture
is to get to something more tangible see
now that we've talked about the chain
rule we've talked about inverse
functions a little bit and talked about
these things from a highly theoretical
point of view
let's go ahead and try to solve a
particularly simple problem by
particularly simple I mean this I have
chosen the numbers to come out in a very
very easy way so we don't get lost in
the maze of details in other words there
is a danger that we will confuse the
computational details with the theory so
to emphasize the theory I've tried to
pick a straightforward simple problem
but let's see how this thing works out
let's suppose that we're given that Y is
equal to 10 to the 4th power and X is
equal to T squared what we would like to
do and by the way notice what this thing
says a given value of T determines both
on X and the y so that makes x and y
functionally related notice that from
the first equation we can find that the
Y DT is 4 T cubed from the second
equation we can find that the X DT is 2
T and if we now use the chain rule dy/dx
will be what it will be dy DT divided by
DX DT and that's just 2 T squared by the
way as a check notice this if Y is equal
to T to the fourth and X is equal to T
squared since T to the fourth is the
square of T squared that says Y is equal
to T squared squared Y is equal to x
squared and if Y is equal to x squared
in this case it's very easy to see that
the Y DX is equal to 2x by the way when
we try to compare these two answers they
look different but that's because
they're expressed in terms of different
variables if we return to our original
equations and we see that X is equal to
T squared X is a synonym for T squared
this is the check that we have received
the right answer by the way before I
conclude today's lecture I would like to
make a rather important aside about
parametric equations
after one works the problem this way and
comes down to the check and says hey
after all of this mess over here I could
have replaced it by just y equals x
squared why did I have to work with this
in the first place we are going to have
many many examples throughout the course
that will illustrate this but at least
once in a lecture I would like to go on
record as pointing out that this pair of
equations tells you much more than this
equation here this equation simply tells
you this if a particle were moving along
a curve with respect to time according
to these equations this equation here
simply tells you what path the particle
would follow namely the parabola y
equals x squared on the other hand these
two equations tell you much more than
that these not only tell you that the
particle moved along the parabola y
equals x squared but rather it tells you
at a particular time the point on the
parabola that the particle was at what I
mean is this as another example suppose
we had y equals T squared and x equals T
if we eliminate T from these two
equations we also find that Y is equal
to x squared yet notice that this is not
the same as our original set of
equations for example here when T is 2
when T is 2 over here what point are we
on as far as the parabola is concerned
when T is 2 this is 2 and this is 4 that
would be the point 2 comma 4 on the
other hand with respect to this equation
when T is 2 X is 4 and Y is 16 you see
both of these particles both of these
particles would follow the same curve
but they are at different points at
different times so don't belittle the
parametric approach having the parameter
T in there tells you more than just what
the path of
motion is it tells you at what time a
particle was at what particular point
well enough about that let's go ahead
and find the second derivative now you
see we already know that dy DX is two T
squared now what we'd like to find is
d2y DX squared again the same basic
definition d2y DX squared the second
derivative is the derivative of the
first derivative that's but the first
derivative we saw was 2t squared so this
is the derivative of 2t squared again
and this is where most of the mistakes
are made people get sloppy they forget
the X's in here they say I know the
derivative of this it's 40 well the
derivative of this is 40 with respect to
T we want to differentiate with respect
to X and whether the way the chain rule
comes in we say okay since t is the
natural variable with respect to which
to differentiate let's do it we'll
differentiate with respect to T but
since the final answer has to be with
respect to X our correction factor by
the chain rule will be DT DX well the
derivative of 2t squared with respect to
T is clearly 4t the derivative of T with
respect to X assuming that we know
something about inverse functions that's
the reciprocal of the X DT we just saw
that the X DT was 2t therefore DT DX is
1 over 2t therefore the correct answer
appears to be 2 again this is why I
picked the simple case given that y
equals x squared we see the glance that
the Y DX is equal to 2x and also at a
glance therefore the d2y DX squared is
equal to 2 by the way that's exactly
what this is equal to you see had we
forgot the chain rule and had we left
this factor out this would have given us
in other words to simply write down that
the answer was 40 which is the most
common mistake that's made would have
given us the wrong answer that's why I
picked such an easy problem you see if I
had picked a tough a computational
problem the theory would have remained
the same but when
got two different answers it would have
been difficult to determine which was
the correct answer and which was the
incorrect answer but again to summarize
today's lecture it was a continuation in
a way of the lecture of last time when
we developed the primary recipe
involving differentials now we applied
that to find something called the chain
rule in the process of emphasizing the
chain rule we talked about the necessity
of knowing something about inverse
functions consequently that dictates
what our next lecture will be concerned
with namely inverse functions and so
until next time goodbye funding for the
publication of this video was provided
by the Gabriella and Paul Rosenbaum
foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate